it's about dang time we finally get to make this coffee
I made breakfast with my kids
and just an entire bag of oranges at this point in the morning
now my kids are just chatting away about scrub daddies
because we saw the Halloween scrub daddies on TikTok Shop and they're obsessed
we had a full 30 minute conversation about the different shapes of scrub daddies
so they should have for different seasons and different events that happened
like why we didn't have shark scrub daddies for Shark Week
I don't even know if those exist
but scrub daddy if you're listening
we need Shark Scrub Daddy
you're probably wondering how we got down this rabbit trail
well my kids love the different coloured scrub daddies
and it has encouraged them to clean
so I'm 100% gonna be buying them in every colour
just so they'll clean their own bathroom
because I am pretty sure those kids get toothpaste everywhere
except their toothbrush